oh hello I'm Nick Kroll my sleeves are
rolled up at an uncomfortable length I'm
going online to answer some questions on
the Internet
this is actually me all right
Twitter hey Nick Kroll I'm seriously
contemplating dressing as Gil faizon for
Halloween can you ask him for tips on
pulling off that look for me okay I
would like to do that but Gil is
currently locked himself into a porta
potti the key to a Gil faizon costume is
corduroy pulling your shirt through your
zipper as if you've dipped it up in a
hurry but do it every day
duct tape on your sport sandals
baggy corduroys really worn out around
the knee and the tush like a worn out
Muppet leather jacket really let those
shoulder pads in the leather jacket
speak but let's let them sag like
they've been worn for a long time and I
voted sticker somewhere on the leather
jacket but again that I voted sticker
you want from an election a long time
ago
and for the wig color-wise what you want
from the wig is for it to look like
someone Ash their cigarette into a bowl
of creamed corn it's actually I want to
know what had to be censored on
Goldberg's door well it's a picture from
an upcoming episode that had an aired
yet I think it's the outcome of the 2018
midterm elections which we kind of know
about at big mouths animation takes so
long that you have to work ahead so they
gave us those results but we can't
reveal that all so let's just look at my
hair real quick look at those edges
shout out to Rudy my barber keep those
at Eddie's toy Submit how to convince my
closed-minded friends to watch big mouth
this is a question I ask myself all the
time how do I get my closed-minded
friends to watch big mouth because I'm
trying to get my friends to watch it oh
I don't know Jordan Peele Jenny slate
Jesse Cline Jason Mantzoukas Maya
Rudolph Fred Armisen John Mulaney
Andrew Rannells richard kind Gina
Rodriguez David Thewlis I mean these are
all people who
answer my text messages Laura it's a
weird word Laura what are nick crawls
best characters my favorite Nick Kroll
character is probably Nick Kroll let's
see what I'm doing big mouth I am the
voice of Nick
I've also the hormone monster a GQ
viewing audience why don't you touch
yourself right now the difference
between them like I am also Lola
I don't like GQ I love pop sugar also
the ladybug that calls out things when
we can't figure out how to end a scene
just like this bit Wikipedia is
Wikipedia different than wiki feet I
donate to wiki feet crawl and Mullaney
develop thighs on and st. geegland for
watching two men wearing turtlenecks and
blazers at the Strand book store
purchase separate copies of Ellen Aldous
book they follow the men into a coffee
shop and soon decided to host the comedy
show as those characters I want to clear
up a little thing what would happen we
went into the coffee shop and then the
coffee shop was struck by lightning and
we had a body switching thing John and I
have been rolling around as these old
men for the last 12 15 years and those
old men are rolling around New York as
US I assume that when me and John meet
the two men who we body switched with I
assume it one it will be at a Steely Dan
concert and two our bodies will switch
then we'll go to a deli and not eat tuna
because I'm actually allergic to tuna
fish fun fact I've been pranking people
too much tuna and if I eat even one ice
cream scooper dollop worth of tuna fish
my face will turn bright red and I'll be
itching my skin off Instagram here we go
oh hello who
do you have bronzer and eyeliner on fair
question I was at the Cannes Film
Festival and a Russian woman did my
makeup it's possible that she put
bronzer on my face and I wouldn't be
surprised if there was a little low
eyeliner in there as well you can't
control Russians when they do your
makeup I guess my question for the
original Lex is how do you feel about
the bronzer and eyeliner cuz I'm not a
mint I stuffed my pants as well I mean
you can't tell that here but I stuck a
whole baguette down the left side of my
pants
Nick Kroll wants Big Mouth season 2 and
most important question will there be
more nathan fillion there is no big
mouth without Nathan Fillion and there
is no Nathan Fillion without big mouth
but also watch the rookie on ABC this
fall Nathan Fillion might be the only
actual celebrity playing himself on big
mouth what a handsome beefy Canadian man
even more Twitter pilar Raleigh's
anybody else concerned about how much
time Nick Kroll spends on insta I'm just
saying he likes a lot of posts I am
concerned about how much time I'm
spending on insta Pilar you and I are on
the same page sister I never think about
the fact that if I like a post other
people see it but I think we should all
be liking everybody's post more people
are putting themselves out there it's
very vulnerable when you post something
on Instagram it's vulnerable we're
looking at likes we're looking at views
social media is a constant living
nightmare that we're all going through
just like everybody [ __ ] always and
everyone will feel so much better
why isn't it cruel good at being the bad
guy in movies I guess I have a face that
people just look at and be like I don't
like that guy I don't think I want to
root for that guy posted seven years ago
I was at my
Malo where you were celebrating your
birthday the next day you tweeted that
somebody stole your presents I was the
only Mexican at the place so I think I'm
leaving to let you know that it wasn't
me
happy birthday by the way that truly was
such a bummer I had a birthday party my
girlfriend had just broken up with me I
had all my presents in like a little bag
by the bar I went outside I came back in
someone had stolen my presence my
friends gave me ride home and I was
drunk and crying that my presents have
been stolen
so Aldo I'm happy to cross you off the
list all right
well this has been so fun I'm gonna go
outside now by a ice cream cone and feed
it to a dog on the street because
nothing is funnier than watching a dog
eat soft-serve but it won't be chocolate
because I don't want the dog to die good
bye everybody